and US News and World Report's as a
breakthrough treatment to fight cancer
has federal approval this morning the
FDA support makes Carty the first
approved gene therapy in the United
States it reprograms the body's own
immune system to attack a deadly type of
blood cancer party was effective in
clinical trials in 83% of children and
young adults with leukemia 12 year-old
Emily Whitehead was a first pediatric
patient to receive this therapy five
years ago she was dying from cancer but
today she is cancer-free researchers
hope that this type of therapy could one
day be used against multiple diseases
our dr. David agus has been following
the testing and approval of the
treatment he leads the USC Westside
Cancer Center and joins us from Los
Angeles David good morning to you good
morning Gail it's very exciting to hear
about Emily's story help us understand
why the medical community is so excited
about this it's being called a new
frontier in medicine oh it's so great to
have a positive story this week and this
is really an amazing story so this is a
treatment different than all other
treatments in cancer you take out the
immune cells from these children who
have end-stage leukemia you send them to
a factory in New Jersey and what happens
is they do gene therapy to put in the
gene to target these immune cells back
to the leukemia they send the cells back
they're infused into the child and 83%
of these children that have failed all
treatment go into remission so this is a
living therapy now the treatments were a
very narrow group of patients so who is
eligible initially so right now it is
children and young adults with a ll a
particular kind of aggressive leukemia
that have failed other treatments but in
the pipeline is lymphoma in adults and
in children David take us through the
cost for this I want to get this right
this is eye popping almost half a
million dollars four hundred
seventy-five thousand that's in line
with certain other therapies but then
the payment for this is also unique
right no question about is that you know
today in Fortune magazine Dana Goldman
an economist at USC and myself have a
piece talking about this realize and put
the four hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars in perspective a
transplant which would be an alternative
treatment
kids cost $800,000 but what novartis the
pharmaceutical company negotiated with
the Center for Medicare Services which
is the US government is that you only
have to pay if the child is in remission
at one month so you only pay if the drug
works and so actually basing the costs
or charge of the drug on value is a
whole new in of way innovative way of
pricing drugs so an innovative treatment
and also innovative payment certainly
for 75,000 is an enormous price but at
the same time it it is you know
different in kids who don't respond and
do respond and when this comes out for
different indications they're gonna
charge different amounts so it's
actually based on what it saves what are
the risk there are real risks to this is
that you're killing lots of cells at
once and you get what's called a
cytokine storm so it's only being
administered right now in 20 centers
that are certified and know how to deal
with this that number will expand over
the next year but it is a difficult
therapy but these kids have no other
choice so to them it is life-saving as
you saw with Emily at the beginning of
the story can you use this on other
diseases or is this only for cancer yes
so you're gonna see if approvals in the
next several months for lymphoma in
adults you also have clinical trials
there are over 50 clinical trials now in
different indications and so these
indications range from other kinds of
cancer like solid tumors to heart
disease and others so it's a very
exciting that we now have a living drug
to treat patients exciting thank you
very much dr. David agus